fida on va faire rentrer tout de suite
deux monuments la chouette éloize
auteurs
[Applaudissements]
là
sescousse épices et
les scieries la
clinique c'étaient des mots du monde tpm
p le mot est faible vraiment alors
est-ce que vous avez reconnu oui oui oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est là votre avis c'est que l on sait
s'il le fait il ne dit pas la main à
l'âme qui était dans la chouette là
maintenant je vous dis qu'est en train
de décider mais je savais pas qui était
un chouette à la balle et j'ai mis ça c
est sa démarche et les chaussures j'ai
tout de suite su que c'était bien sûr
c'était bien sûr c'est bien sûr c'est
bien sûr
c'est tellement heureux de vous voir
parce que c'est vrai que je vous aime
tellement tous les deux capus qui a été
vraiment on a on a fait des rigolades
mais je te jure mais quelle rigolade
alors c'est vrai que je me rappelle
quand vous aviez décroché votre premier
prime voilà c'est mon meilleur souvenir
parce que vraiment j'ai eu une montée
d'émotion ouais mais incroyable en fait
je m'y attendais pas du tout je pensais
pas que je pouvais offrir cette chance à
quelqu'un qui débute comme moi est en
fait voilà
tu en fasses de koh lanta l'avait fait
730 milles
alors on va revoir ce moment quand avait
décroché d'ombré me sentais plus beaux
souvenirs de télé mais c'est clairement
mon plus beau souvenir de toute ma
carrière entre guillemets si je peux
dire carrière derrière moi si tu as fait
l'intérieur moitié madagascar est rien
on arrête tu arrives tu n'as pas de
petite carrière une carrière c'est une
tare yard merci ça la capucine votre
cadeau de noël
[Applaudissements]
hu
mais je veux bien quoi animer avec lui
si on l'espère si la double peine
c
tu as cru d'abord la quatre voies merci
mille fois encore parce que c'était ce
direct et mais incroyable et ce moment
là en fait je me rappelle il y avait une
histoire un petit peu éventuellement de
tri les cheveux en appel et en fait je
pensais tellement qu'on m'avait fait une
blague je m'attendais pas du tout à ce
qui est le prince je me suis c'est la
prod qui me piège je vais vous raconter
je raconte un truc ça cette affaire un
jeu vous dites waouh je me raconte un
vrai que je suis on appelle ces piscines
récompensé de son excellent ça sur le
sol tant que je le voyais pas comme ça
me rappelle très très bien je vous jure
que c'est vrai je vous racontais
l'histoire c'est que il y avait c'était
le le week end c'était le samedi et on
avait appris que sur la chaîne une
chaîne concurrente sur le toque
concurrents et à la voir emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron était en face et j'ai
dit aux équipes il faudrait qu'on ait un
truc qu en face qui sont autre chose
soit un feuilleton et jeux réunis mais
ressortez mois les images de capucine
quant à lui eu en prime et donc on a
ressources et des images jordi envoyez
les moi je regarde les images et je vois
que capucine à tricher j'apprends et je
crois qu'ils attribuent ce jeudi lundi
on va faire huit ans capucine qui a
triché parce que c'est inadmissible déjà
vous le savez rallye mode et bien et les
autres je déteste quand on triche et je
leur avais dit vous allez voir capucine
qui a triché ça sera plus qu emmanuel
macron
c'est bon ou pas et l'audience à mettet
non mais à part ça et là l'émission
avait été incroyable ça avait été une
enquête pendant l'émission c'est vrai
que capucine vous avez triché mais vu
que mais je vous le dis franchement je
ne regrette pas de vous avoir donné le
prime parce que sinon ça aurait été de
l'embout qu'il avait
il avait déjà animé par fabien sur moi
vraiment s'empêcher bongo bah oui enfin
26 25 c mais c'était incroyable mais
direct en plus on m'avait enlevé le
prompteur on m'a dit fais comme cyril
tantes enlève le prompteur la dernière
minute ça ne me dit pas prompte à rien
j'ai fait mais comment je vais faire oui
cela était dû à la salle a franchement
de trois ans
[Rires]
et avec des pics et lente
sacrée entre vous m'aviez vraiment
laisser libre choix vous m'avez dit
capucine sait-on prime tu fais ce que tu
veux et moi j'adore la danse
ça a commencé et c'était incroyable
bonjour miquel alors bonjour me c'est
une légende inventée pmp bassim ainsi
l'arrêt jean michel mr bah si si c'est
vrai mon agent me traiter les gens de
tpm paix et on va revoir juste une de
tes vannes vers les basketteurs résume
bien cela
c'est super épreuve mais ça n'a aucun
intérêt ça vous dit de rester 32 35
minutes devant devant deux personnes
debout sur un poteau vois tu es bien
deux heures sur une top 3
[Applaudissements]
non
k
[Applaudissements]
moi
ce que j'aime c'est la hague sur la
médecine à
certains des plus grands fous rires nani
chabanon moi moi moi me fous rires de ma
vie de l'histoire de thé pembe c'est
quand jour mis d'accord l'aveyronnais a
sauté à la corde
janadi je n'ai jamais dis c'est que
en fait c'était le jury de je savais
iront en jean mi melle de m'a souvent
dit qu'il n'avait pas de slip et
jeudi on croit jeudi la premier league
mais tu aimais un truc et je le vois un
saute comme ça et orange unis mais n'en
faut que tu sautes comme ça
et je sais dans ma tête et après c'est
après qui m'a dit t'es vraiment un chien
ta g c'est un pantalon feutrine et je
l'aï reconnu me condamne à tort et à
chaque bon jeu sont exilés sondés mais
j'ai fait sur ces gagner un portable
c'est ça un portable au bout des 10 et à
set j'ai senti vraiment que ça
reste plus 3 sauf où je termine ça
franchement c'était incroyable et la
personne d'ailleurs qui est devant vous
et bien de vue
personnel rêve encore
assez d'accord aujourd'hui c'est lé
moment incroyable abbas se disant je
suis arrivé à la première et à chaque
fois on dit chaque année parce qu'on
fait une dernière chaque année je remis
ça a été le premier c'était le pote de
monde associe yannick serré et yannick
le connaissais un peu de mon associé et
il dit franchement il y avait bien une
rabat sur le vivrais pas post a imposé
alors ils imposent j'ai mis un nom mais
n'a pas posé me l'a suggéré en tout il
m'a dit si je suis un mec qui est bien
je pense qu'il serait pas mal ouais ça
aurait fait venir et alors je vais vous
dire je vous lis jean michel lemaire au
départ je le redis encore une fois
c'était le mec du figaro à tripoli a
parié avec moi je pensais pas du tout
que j'allais faire des marques avec le
mien je me suis dit oui et même au début
d'ailleurs rigolez pas trop je sais pas
quand il ya eu la bascule au
début il est né en dessous l'intello du
post
si vous trouvez ce truc comme excellents
et pastel intitulé
jeudi des corps et débris
jonchant la normale
j'arrivais debby chan partie des mines
[Applaudissements]
et capoue s'éteindrait
capulet nouveau coach est arrivé en même
temps que géraldine et benjamin exact
est très serré c'est vrai que benji
également fourni ni moi j'ai
l'impression ensuite en disant je
restais disant à peu près en disant j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait plus de choses
que dans les 50 premières années de ma
vie franchement j'ai vécu tellement de
choses incroyables tellement marrer et
de payer aussi bien à rien [ __ ] à se
marrer il m'a dit t'as jamais investir
est que tu as c'est vraiment un truc à
rabat ces commentaires ont plus ou moins
plus je vieillis plus j'ai envie de me
marrer j'ai envie de légèreté et là
c'était fantastique fantastic m'a écouté
de ses comptes et j'en reviens toujours
enfin je fais jean iv tous les soirs
façon je suis je sais pas surfer dessus
et si je commande tout seul je dis un
jour et je sais ce que c'est vrai qu'il
y ait envie qu'on en parle j'en parle
c'est jeudi jeudi tout je t'appelle
souvent honte apparition pour faire tpm
pays pourquoi tu voues - le faire mais
parce que je sais que je t'appelle il
l'appelle souvent et 6 mai encore il
pensait deux semaines début de semaine
un peu dormi j'ai envie que ce soit avec
nous tout cas vers lionel salmon envoyé
un message rappelle moins urgent mais
oui tout de suite su qu'il voulait que
je fasse émissions et honnêtement je
suis bien je la regarde meja pression
d'avoir fait mon temps et puis j'ai pas
envie de revenir comme un remplaçant
toute l'équipe est très bien donc je la
regarde je me marre j'aurais
l'impression qu'on la place de quelqu'un
d'autre mais voilà moi ma place me va
très bien j'ai 60 ans maintenant je suis
chez moi je les engage la commente avec
mon chien est
ce que tu dis tu seras bien plus avec
nous le sort du truc on n'est plus
tellement dans le truc que je craquais
sûr je serai moins pas moins bon habana
lente et que gt gt bond était très haut
car là je suis le meilleur c'est le
meilleur moment
tous les sons qui sont maintenant sont
très bons et moi je j'adore regarder
j'arrête tous les soirs je regardais le
je rate jamais un auteur on peut
toujours trouver une place un non non
non je très bien mais je peux encore des
séries et c'est vrai que j'ai mis les
voiles assez regardé c'est
incroyable dit un mot sur jean remis
parce que bien sûr ça fait des années
que je le connais et c'est un type qui a
une carrière formidable c'est quelqu'un
d'une humilité dire loyauté d'une
sympathique pouvait toujours compter sur
lui vraiment jean-mi je suis fier d'être
ton ami et merci pour eux aussi dans la
rue
jean mines qui est vraiment alors ils
sont tous ceux comme ils sont dans la
vie ici mes jours me c'est vraiment
c'est le même coin c'est margaret oui
mais c'est vrai que vraiment et moi
aujourd'hui je peux l'appeler n'importe
quand il sait très bien que la wii est
toujours là je tourne je sais jamais
craqué je n'ai jamais aimé incroyable
voilà c'est vraiment un mec que j'aime
chez christine qu'il aime beaucoup il
adore vraiment en plus et quand j'étais
à ses côtés but je rêve parce que j'aime
rêver demain soir à chaque fois que tu
es venu parce que qu'est-ce qu'on se
marre est pas en un pub à chaque fois
c'était des délires incroyable et dire
qu'il a été reporter de guerre
on a tous mesure vie voilà je me
souviens qu'il a eu plusieurs vies mais
aussi bien sûr et je me souviens que tpm
pays endettement ah oui c'est vrai
pratiquement bah oui on est franchement
pas quand je pense à mon boulot je pense
qu'à tmp je pense pas au figaro le 15
non je pense plus on a écouté mano de
ses comptes m on mêle je sais je sais
mais moi je tiens bon tu seras toujours
voilà le bilan des choses c'est le jury
non je vous le dis je te dis on veut que
tu viennes avec nous plus souvent voilà
je peux l'éviter
[Applaudissements]
bon ok